hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm with my beautiful wife amanda hey
guys amanda lee's here and
we're going to be talking in this video
about electric
cars we finally buckled under the
pressure and decided to go electric
i know well i mean i've still got i've
still got a big petrol machine here
but we're not going to be talking about
the range today we're going to be
talking about amanda's
brand new mercedes eqc
[Music]
now listen i haven't seen this yet this
literally this has been on the driveway
about 24 hours and i just got back from
an event last night so this is the first
time i've literally seen i've never been
inside it or anything like that
i mean looking wise because you ordered
you wanted to order black i did i did
but then they only had
this gray in stock to me this does not
this is
black to me i mean it does not really
look it doesn't really look like great i
like it i like it
i know i know what do you think of the
look of it i think it was great i think
it was i mean
what more importantly what do you what
do you what do you think of them i'm
actually really
pleased and surprised because i didn't
know that i'd love it as much as i do
yeah i'm really really pleased with it
and we're gonna take a spin in a few
minutes
yeah okay so literally like it
e eqc good
is it is this technically is it a four
by four
so take the well it is yeah it's a four
by four yes
i kind of feel like it looks smaller
than it probably is because just because
i've got
oh there we go okay
decent size we can get the buggy in
which is great yeah and then it comes
with like this cable if you want to plug
it into somewhere
because we got we got three kids now so
we needed a car
that was going to be big enough to get
three car seats in the back so
let's check out the back i like this i
like a lot i don't know if that is
optional
i'm not actually does it hold the weight
of samuel leaves
yes it does in that case it's solid
oh wow all three car seats fit in there
see i don't think
i don't think i'm actually ever going to
get to go in this car i think this is uh
this is amanda in the kitchen
to be fair i am impressed that it's got
three car seats because
three car seats that's some serious
space yeah these aren't small car seats
either our kids are getting big i know
so
like that come on man talk us through
whatsoever
so you step into the car
it's very nice it is isn't it and look
at this rose gold detailing there which
is quite nice did you
specifically say you wanted rose gold or
was that coincidence it was just a
coincidence but i like it
it's nice but you went for what what
range is this because this is i think
this is like the top yeah so this is the
highest spec that you can get this in
and it's the
premium plus okay um amg
premium plus amg like i don't even know
what that means i know
it's like the best the the best one that
they have here's the interesting thing
whether you prefer this car or whether
you like the petrol version
maybe you've got agendas i mean talk to
me about how does the electric work
because
that was the big thing that put you off
yeah so i was really worried because i
just thought the inconvenience of having
to stop
on top of your car all the time might be
really annoying but it actually has
234 miles range when it's fully charged
that's a lot of miles yeah it is you
wouldn't drive
further than that in one yeah well for
me i'm pretty local just
around the area bit of a local girl
local girl i've also got my charger
oh yeah so literally every time i get
home
i then just plug it in how much did this
cost uh it was around 600 pounds
was it tax deductible yes it was was is
is
is the entire 900 pound a month tax
deductible yes it is
absolutely everything listen listen let
me explain this so you understand
so this car right here okay if you're
gonna lease this car
which is a petrol car you're gonna have
to pay for it
personally which means that you have to
take money out of your company
okay as a dividend or as a wage or
whatever
and when you take money out of your
company what do you have to do pay tax
yep
so you could and it could be like 40 tax
maybe more
and then with what's left you pay for
the car
with electric cars like this car
you don't have to pay for it your
company can pay for it and what
percentage can you claim back is tax
deductible
100 100 which is crazy
electric cars not only the car so not
only the lease
the um the tax even the insurance
every penny that you pay towards having
that vehicle
is as tax right off so financially it
just makes absolute sense
um to have the car what we're worried
about is electric is that going to work
how's it going to drive we'll find out
in a minute so tell me how this works
leader
so get home plug it in
and then it just charges it up until
it's 100 and then when it's 100
it stops charging so wait come on let's
do this it might be a bit too far
is it okay oh let's
look back that's like that feeling when
you get to the petrol station
it's just not gonna put it back
oh yes all right
so how do you do this
sir you push that over nice
stick it right in is that on charge now
yep can you hear that
i can even see the things little yeah
and then on my phone i haven't got my
phone on the app it then pops up saying
um it's charging your car it tell me how
much percentage i have and then it will
say
it will be 100 in so many then you have
to come out and take it out or not no no
just leave it just don't win it yeah so
when it stop when it finishes charging
it just cuts out and then
that's it you just leave that in all
night yeah nice
yeah so that's cool i want to see how
this drives do you want to drive it or
do you want me to drive it
um i think i want you to drive it i want
you to see what it feels like
oh my goodness this is
weird it goes so fast like literally
it takes off really quick oh my goodness
it doesn't make a sound no is that even
safe
would anyone hear you coming i know
that's what i think all the time i
always think no one can probably hear
you come in really
it is bad it's crazy this is beautiful
you must be so happy with this car
i am really really pleased this is way
better than the discovery
it's got a big boot it's got three car
seats in the back
i know it's everything i need i can't
believe it so let's say you did decide
to drive somewhere really far
yeah you went to a lot i don't know
leeds which is four hours from our house
yeah and you ran out of electorate
so i'd probably plan my journey and then
this is where you lose me yeah plan my
journey
see where there's a stop that i can stop
at with the charge point which
most services now i think all of them
have charge points but also the benefit
actually
at the services is that they're all
supercharge points
so instead of it taking however long it
takes at home can i just say
actually really really fast this drives
nicer
than my range rover and your range rover
drives really nice range overdrive
this drives nicer than my range rover oh
my god goodness you never hear me coming
man oh my goodness
this is unreal
i'm getting one when my range rover ends
when does when does my is mine on a
lease my range mine's not really you
bought it
i think yours i think it's on a pcp
yeah anyway whenever it comes to an end
guess what i'm getting the electric car
oh yeah you'd have to be a bit more
not so spontaneous with your journey do
you reckon that well because you travel
up and down the country but how long
does it take to top up an electric car
not long might take half an hour to get
to fully charged well if you're driving
to friggin
school yeah that's true i love it i want
to turn around which is amazing
and it breaks nice it
just i love that the thing's here as
well
i know it's cool it's really convenient
rather than having to mess around down
here
yeah it is just do you like it
i absolutely love it i'm sold babe this
is nicer than your discovery sport
oh yeah it definitely drives it's so
smooth
look does it steer where you want it to
stare it does have that lane there no it
doesn't yeah
even let me try i don't know if it's oh
maybe not maybe not maybe just on the
motorway oh it's not activated
oh i don't know how to activate i
haven't explored it that much oh
man but and it's also have you seen the
the head up display so can you see the
what the speed ahead of you what so the
speed should be showing up there
oh it does can you see so you can see
how fast you're going yeah without
having to look down at the dashboard
brilliant did you see the story about
the guy that was driving the tesla
drunk man fell asleep and the tesla
realized he was sleeping
and pulled him over to a safe bay wow
smart car
yeah so what is if you're gonna go
electric what's the advantage why did
you choose not to go tesla why did you
go mercedes
i don't know um because at the time i
just thought that the mercedes looked
cooler than tesla
i think that the teslas are cool they're
just a different look aren't they
yeah um i just wanted my car to look
like a normal
normal car yeah as opposed to like a
spaceship yeah as opposed to something
that looks a bit more futuristic it's
not really
what i wanted yeah but i feel like
as the years go by there's going to be
even more and more options so
yeah i think electric is the way to go i
feel as well
you know when you go from an automatic
car well to a to an automatic from a
manual
and you feel like i'm never ever going
to drive a manual again yeah
i feel that now that i've got an
electric i don't feel like i'd ever go
back
to petrol petrol or diesel car
yeah hold on
hey have you ever thought about going
electric
have you ever thought about going
electric yes it's the best
i know why do you not drive electric
it's about
money man oh dude it is
all right i'll see you soon brother
there's not even a handbrake it's crazy
so overall what would you rate the car
out of 10
it's 10 out of 10. 10 out of 10.
it's so good the question is i know
people are going to be saying this
you're going to be saying
but why did you just lease it why don't
you buy it obviously we've been really
blessed we're doing quite well
financially
while if you give it a 10 out of 10 and
you love it to bits why wouldn't you buy
it why are you leasing it
wouldn't buy it because i think it only
makes sense to buy things that are going
to go up in value cars and they
depreciate
there's no benefit i can't know what the
exact stat was but someone said
if you bought a tesla 10 years ago now
your money's going to be of shrank but
if you put the money into a tesla's
stock
you'd be a multi-millionaire so we put
our money into things that go up
namely property we don't just go up in
value also give us rent what do we do
with the rent
then we pay for cars these cars and do
we pay tax
nope why because the government are
trying to incentivize people to go
electric apparently it's better for the
planet i'm not really sure
i think it is less emissions less
emissions better for the planet
tax efficient drive super smooth love it
world and babe 10 out of 10.
hey for more videos like this don't
forget to subscribe subscribe to the
channel up here if you want to see our
house tour
oh you can check out the house store
right up here and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
two